well career day in elementary school is
a great chance to get kids dreaming
about their futures when they can grow
up and become teachers doctors and
apparently cop haters one elementary
school in Chicago enraged parents
understandably after its principal
invited an activist to the school who
routinely posts violent anti-cop
rhetoric online Fox's Matt Finn was
contact about this reported it and has
all the details Matt Tucker that Chicago
elementary school principal Marybeth
Kunitz
suddenly retired with just weeks left in
the school year it happened after she
invited a police extremist to talk to
students at Wildwood elementary school
here in Chicago that extremists on
social media calls himself a radical in
February when a Chicago police commander
was shot and killed execution-style
Ethos posted online F him and his family
ethos also post the term CPD K which
stands for Chicago Police Department
killers the anti police extremist refers
to cops as pigs and posted about killing
all the rich people ethos has hatred for
police because he alleges that a Chicago
police officer killed his friend with a
Taser the school principal says she
brought in this anti police extremist to
talk to students about his poetry and
civic work but things went off the rails
we talked to one mother whose three
children listen to ethos on career day
he told them that all the police were
bad and all the police wanted to kill
people I was very disappointed that
someone would come into the school and
preach hate about the police or even if
he was talking about anyone else it
would have upset me Mary Beth Cunha
wrote a letter of apology before
resigning writing in part I was present
when his narrative took a negative turn
about policing at which point I
immediately intervened I care about your
children I would never intentionally
expose them to or endorse this type of
negativity
some parents dispute that qu not
immediately intervened saying ethos
spoke to a few classes without
interruption and that qu not the
principal has recently been pressured by
some parents to introduce anti police
philosophies to students nearly every
parent we talked to said the principal
was doing an excellent job but ended up
making this great mistake we talked to
one Chicago police officer who
children went to the school he says the
career day speech was an indoctrination
and now the students have been exposed
to ethos online accounts insulted angry
I can't believe that she didn't vet him
properly look on his Facebook account
because some of the things that are in
his facebook account are absolutely
horrible Ethos declined our request for
an interview the Chicago School District
says it was not aware of ethos and did
not approve him speaking to students I
briefly spoke to Mary Beth Cunha on the
phone and she emphasizes that she
suddenly retired and did not resign with
many years left in her contract tucker
matt fin from chicago thank you